je vous confirme qu'à partir de janvier
2024 on pourra passer le permis de
conduire à partir de 17 ans et conduire
à partir de 17 ans ça concerne tous les
jeunes mais ça n'intéresse pas forcément
un jeune qui habite dans une ville très
bien desservie par les transports en
commun il y a certaines associations qui
averti sur une certaine forme de
dangerosité qu'est-ce que vous leur
répondez on est évidemment très attentif
sur le niveau qui sera le même qui est
demandé pour un jeune pour passer pour
avoir son permis de conduire on est
aussi en train de renforcer
l'attestation de sécurité routière pour
en faire des sortes de précodes on peut
constater dans les pays chez nos voisins
qui ont fait le permis à 17 ans il y a
pas eu plus d'accidents
par exemple à 17 ans les jeunes ils
peuvent conduire pas le soir sauf si il
travaille à certaines heures 15 ans
tu passes une marche arrière et tu te
demandais en automatique ta ton permis
non mais pour moi c'est très bien à 17
ans
je suis perplexe avec ça j'ai du mal
parce que la responsabilité civile 17
ans tu es pas un majeur qui sait qui
c'est qui est responsable et en même
temps je me dis c'est moins dangereux
que de voir tous ces tous ces jeunes de
14-15 ans avec des petites voitures sans
permis me dit quand je les vois quand je
les vois moi je suis en camion ils font
n'importe quoi de sortie de voiture sans
permis je mets peut-être que c'est bien
de mettre le permis à 17 ans mais là
c'est sous tutelle des parents alors ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que si le
petit à 17 ans il fait le dinguerie
c'est le parent qui est votre tribunal
c'est quoi c'est la responsabilité du
parent c'est quand même là-dessus tu
vois plus de couilles et dire voilà si
tu veux que ce soit un petit bonhomme et
qui conduise comme un petit bonhomme de
18 ans et il va être responsable à 17
ans et fais attention tu veux conduire à
17 ans c'est très bien parce qu'il faut
pas penser que Paris il y a des mecs en
milieu rural à la campagne ils ont des
formations à les faire il faut qu'ils
aillent bosser à 17 ans il leur faut une
voiture il leur faut une voiture c'est
assez jeune là cette nouvelle c'est quoi
ça de quoi de parler tout ça maintenant
[Rires]
mais ça me fait peur parce que le samedi
soir du samedi dimanche on sait très
bien c'est des jeunes de 18 19 20 ans
qui se tuent énormément en voiture
j'aurais préféré qu'on augmente
[Musique]
les navettes pour aller boîte de nuit
par exemple je dis pas n'importe quoi
c'est quoi cette nouvelle vidéo
mais je suis d'accord parce que les
émissions
ça va augmenter j'ai bien peur les
risques de de de
pour les sorties
[Rires]
c'est nul c'est nul la chute c'est nul
c'est nul à chier
voilà c'est surtout pour les apprentis
faut pas d'études longues bah écoute
avant de parler et qui des saisons
trouvent un boulot et qui peuvent du
coup aller au travail articule
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette équipe
dans la bouche
ça c'est
plus arrêté